that's what it's like on fox you can't
see a damn thing
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream i am dr brett
weinstein and i am sitting today with dr
heather heing from an undisclosed
bedroom in our house the reason for this
is that well it's not entirely clear it
sort of seems that heather might have
covid do you know what says she has
covid she has the symptoms of omicron a
doctor confirms that it sounds like
omicron do you know what doesn't say
that she has covid covid tests
so in any case we're doing the uh
responsible thing
we are attempting to live by cdc
guidelines for a household in which
somebody has
a presumed case of kovid
i think it is fair to say it will
certainly emerge in discussion here i
think it is fair to say that we don't
believe any of this makes sense in light
of the uh the
ferocious contagion that is omicron um
which is uh very hard to control but in
any case we will get to that
this is live stream number 110
is that correct heather that is right
all right um we're back after a break of
three weeks
which is why despite the uh the the
chaos here for the last certainly hour
and uh to some degree a day or two uh we
are coming to you live even though it is
not optimal
yes now i will say today's show is
brought to you by the letter omicron and
the variable x
and uh it is not a palindrome but we
promise you a palindromic show uh
sometime soon perhaps in the upcoming
week
uh we have a little bit of
business to do here but before that
let's just set out a goal for today's
podcast
i think that by the end of today's
podcast our audience should be able
to
to make a credible argument as to
whether we are broadcasting of covid or
with kovit
[Laughter]
i mean that seems that's you know it's
not too high it's a high bar but it's
not too high a bar it's not too hard bar
no i think i think that's excellent yeah
this is uh we you know we we had some
great plans and most of them kind of
went to the wind so we're gonna we're
gonna be flying by the seat of our pants
a little bit here today but yeah let's
get the business out of the way shall we
yeah let's get the business out of the
way and by the business heather means
the paying of the uh the literal
mortgage which we do through our
courageous sponsors not yet nope
not yet oh wait we'll get to the
courageous sponsors and in the time that
it takes to get there they will become
presumably even a little more courageous
oh my god okay let's just get through
this okay
this is harder without being in the same
room i can't kick you under the table
which i never ever do right now but i
know that you could and it keeps me in
line exactly and you know that i can't
now um
okay so um
uh usually we talk about where we're
going today we're just we're gonna riff
a lot on
the kron and other things related to
coven uh today we continue to encourage
you to find a hunter gatherer's guide to
the 21st century if you haven't
found it yet uh we are we continue to be
uh thrilled and pleased by the
perception it's getting and by how many
languages it's being translated into
what the sales look like how many
libraries are having to buy multiple
copies it's wonderful and we'd love to
hear questions about it follow-ups all
of that
we're streaming for now on both youtube
and odyssey the chat is live on odyssey
consider
asking questions for our q a in the next
hour at
www.darkhorsesubmissions.com we already
have a number in i saw i don't haven't
seen the questions yet but i've seen
evidence in my email that questions are
coming in so that's great
uh consider joining one or both of our
patreons at mine we have a private q a a
two hour private q a on the last sunday
of every month and we invite questions
um earlier in the month and brett does a
couple of
uh of um fairly intimate conversations
with people at higher um higher dollar
amounts
in usually the first weekend of the
month but it's delayed a little bit or
first yeah i'm confused
we have
stuff at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org nothing new
since before christmas but we got
direwolves we got an epic tabby we got
some digital book burning
all that uh and consider joining me at
my sub stack
naturalselections.substack.com
where the last two entries i was going
to take a break from that like i was go
like we took a break from the podcast
for three weeks for two weeks
but i found myself
writing
writing about covid and experiences with
i may i may yet do that a third time
this upcoming week since uh since now
the omicron omicron is with us but go
there and and find find those things now
now we are prepared to pay
uh the rent by appreciating our sponsors
i knew it was gonna happen
you knew it was gonna happen okay we
have as has become our want three
sponsors today
are we
ready
i think we're ready all right since i so
i'm
i'm in the bedroom i can't see anything
about what anyone else can see except i
can see brett that's it
our first sponsor today is new to us
ned
ned is a cbd company that stands out in
a highly saturated cbd market
ned was started by two friends who
discovered that their hyper modern lives
were leaving them feeling empty
bewildered and disconnected something
about this way of life they say on their
website just wasn't working so they
started dead
you can buy cbd products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store as most of
you have probably noticed by now at
least if you're in the us but ned's
de-stress blend and sleep blend in
particular really impressed us people
use cbd for these and other purposes
including reducing pain anxiety and
inflammation and again we're impressed
many of the cbd companies out there
source their hemp from industrial farms
in china just like with low quality
alcohol however low quality cbd can have
undesired effects
ned is usda certified organic
all of ned's full spectrum hemp oil is
extracted from usda certified organic
hemp plants grown by an independent
farmer named jonathan in peonia colorado
you can go onto the web and google
peonia colorado and see what a beautiful
place the cbd the the
hemp being grown
for ned's products is being grown also
ned shares third party lab reports and
information about who farms their
products and their extraction process
right on their site
these products are science-backed nature
based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs they are chock
full of premium cbd and a full spectrum
of active cannabinoids terpenes
flavonoids and trichomes
ned's full spectrum hemp oil nourishes
the body's endocannabinoid
endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance
if you'd like to give another try dark
horse listeners get 15 off ned products
with the code darkhorse
visit helloned.com darkhorse to get
access that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d
dot com slash darkhorse to get 15 off we
want to thank ned again for sponsoring
the show and offering our listeners a
natural remedy for some of life's most
common health issues
our second sponsor for this week
you will regular listeners will and
viewers will be very familiar with it's
vivo barefoot
most shoes are not made for your feet
they're made for someone's idea of what
feet should be and be constrained by and
usually that someone doesn't actually
know feet or what they can do
if you feel barefoot and contrast nose
feet vivobarefoot isn't driven by
fashion you can tell because the shoes
aren't really all that attractive
actually but man oh man are these shoes
a revelation we love these shoes they're
beyond comfortable the tactile feedback
from the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing and they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they are fantastic
our feet are the products of millions of
years
of evolution
i deleted the word evolution from the
script somehow
humans evolved to walk move and run
barefoot but modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted foot function
and are contributing to a health crisis
one in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by
sixty percent in a matter of months just
by walking around in them
we keep running out we keep running into
people out in the world who commented
the vivo barefoots we're wearing and
they're wearing them too it's an odd
little club but it's growing once people
start wearing these shoes they don't
seem to stop so go to vivobarefoot.com
darkhorse to get an exclusive offer of
20 off additionally all new customers
get a 100 day free trial so you can see
if you love them as much as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash darkhorse
now i believe
it's not that they don't look great it's
that our minds have been trained badly
by a form over function world and when
you wear vivo barefoots you look smart
in fact i have my eye on a set of hiking
boots that they make which i'm very
excited to try
all right our third sponsor is all form
sofas and i should tell you i am wearing
something that is not my reading glasses
because my reading glasses don't
interface with these headphones which i
have to uh wear because you know
quarantine and safety first
so
this may break down into me just simply
riffing on what a great sofa this is
which i feel fully qualified to do uh
having built this one up from the boxes
that it came in
uh all form is a company that makes
absolutely terrific sofas they're custom
what makes the sofa so terrific for a
fraction of the cost of traditional
sofas you can customize size layout
fabric and color they do arm chairs and
love seats all the way up to an eight
seat sectional and you can start small
and buy more seats later on without
needing to get a whole new sofa
form sofas are delivered directly to
your home free and fast and assembly is
easy that's really true
we've got a beautiful sectional all-form
sofa in whiskey leather it's soft and
supple and warm unlike a lot of leather
and we pile on to watch movies uh some
evenings it looks gorgeous and it's
incredibly inviting and comfortable a
rare combination we like it so much that
we've got a second one on order that is
true we love the sofa and we're gonna
get another one and actually the one we
already have we are looking to
reconfigure it just by reorganizing the
way the parts are put together that's
not something you can do with most sofas
so
uh some listeners asked if all form
holds up to pets yes it absolutely does
the leather that all form uses is about
20 percent thicker than typical
furniture leather and shows no wear
despite the fact that both cats and the
dog lie on the couch many evenings
and if you prefer fabric all for all
form fabrics are three and a half times
more durable than the industry standard
for heavy duty fabrics so their fabrics
are going to hold up really well with
pets also
finally they offer a forever warranty
literally forever
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
darkhorse all form is offering 20 off
all orders to our listeners at
allform.com
darkhorse a-l-l-f-o-r-m-com
all right
there we go
what should we talk about today brett
well
um let's talk about the predicament
that people such as ourselves who let's
face it what we did when kovitt
descended on the world
was after
[Music]
zach and i made a number of midnight
runs to our downtown studio to recover
all of the equipment for this uh for the
dark horse podcast and built the studio
into our home here you and i started
live streaming and what we were really
doing was trying to sort out in all of
the chaos of the information that was
circulating surround sars cov2 and the
disease covet 19 that it causes we
started to use our generalist
evolutionary toolkit to sort out what it
all meant and people watched as our
model of what this was which was
initially crude got better and better
and it helped to inform them as to how
one might reasonably live in the time of
covid how one might protect themself
from the disease and
from contracting the pathogen
and that was going really
spectacularly well for a while until we
hit a tripwire the tripwire involved
certain things that the public health
authority for reasons that were not
clear did not want to talk about um that
started with the question of
certain prophylactic treatments that
might help avoid covid um i think um i
think you're actually forgetting um you
know the first tripwire was lab leak of
course well
that is true that's you know that's
almost a year before
we started talking about um
off uh off label use for
uh drugs for
prophylaxis and treatment of covin uh so
you know it's we weren't we weren't
playing by narrative rules ever
um and we weren't even on narrative
um for very long uh and in fact
as you said we started in march of 2020
in part because the messaging that we
saw was so incoherent it just it just
made no sense
and uh we thought frankly that we could
uh we could add some clarity which i
think in large part we have done yeah it
uh it was absolutely incoherent and it
did not give people a sense of what they
could do to take control of their lives
again and i will just remind people of
some highlights that i've been thinking
about this week of things that we
thought might be useful and we
discovered as evidence came in about how
the virus actually transmits
our model altered so initially people
who have been with us from the beginning
will remember
that we were doing things like wearing
sacrificial gloves when we went out so
that you could touch things if you touch
the virus you then come home you strip
your clothes off you put them in the
washer you go take a shower you throw
away the gloves or you put them in the
washer
these were all things that were sars
cov2 transmitted by foamite might well
have been useful
we were also very early
on the question of masks much earlier
than the people surrounding us here in
portland
it turns out that masks especially cloth
masks are not particularly useful the
evidence does not support that so
people have watched our model get better
and better we also had uh copper tape on
our doorknobs because this uh it will
interrupt the transmission of certain
viruses and doorknobs are a place where
they're very likely to be transmitted
from one person to another for obvious
reasons so anyway all of these things
are stages where we contemplated
something that might be useful and
ultimately discovered that it wasn't
that the evidence didn't support it and
so our model of how to protect yourself
got better and better it started
focusing on things like
spending as much time outside as
possible both because you generate
vitamin d outside at least in the summer
this far in the temperate zone
because the virus doesn't transmit
outdoors very well now of course we
don't really know what the truth of
omicron is but
so far the outdoor environment has been
much more
as much safer and so we watched the
public health authorities telling people
to stay home and lock themselves in the
environment where people were mostly
contracting the virus and it was warning
them away from the very places that they
could go to feel sane to have normal
interactions and uh we raised the alarm
about this we were also very early in
pointing out that there was uh an
important question about air circulation
and that even an indoor environment
could be made much safer by paying
attention to the way air circulates or
stagnates and doing things to adjust
that parameter
and
we've done quite well
that said
omicron is a very different beast it is
incredibly contagious and people
i'm sure around the country and the
world are experiencing what we're
experiencing where every context that we
are interact with people virtually or
otherwise we're discovering that lots
and lots of people who are a degree of
uh
a degree of separation or two away from
us have covid mostly
it is milder than delta there certainly
appears to be a lot less severe illness
but in any case we are we are grappling
with a new
paradigm that said
the public health advice
that we are given changes very little
almost irrespective of what the virus
does and this in many ways appears to
bear out what we have been arguing for
many many months which is that something
is driving our public health advice and
messaging that is not about either
containing the virus or reducing its
harm and that is a very frightening
thing to have concluded but nonetheless
the fact that omicron has not caused our
public health authorities to completely
revise their advice
is evidence that they are at best not
paying attention to the change in the
disease
so we are living by or we are trying to
live by cdc guidelines here for people
who are believed to have kovid and are
or believed to have contacted them but
we also know from the evidence that that
is almost certain to be futile that
there is no way that it can contain a
virus with people uh living together
and
so
we find ourselves in a similar position
as we do with masks where when asked to
put on masks we put them on despite the
belief that it is not a very useful
mechanism for controlling spread
well
so we're obviously we're not in the same
room and so this is this is a totally
different situation it's very hard to
really have a conversation but i think
um
i think the fact is
that as we said i believe
on on the last time that we were live
with people um omicron if it showed up
now
wouldn't be getting any attention if it
showed up as the first time that anyone
on earth had met sarsko v2 it wouldn't
it wouldn't merit attention at all right
it's just
it's just that minor for most people and
some people are hospitalized and some
people are dying but in terms of highly
transmissible but you know really low
level of disease that seems to be the
the mo of this of this variant by and
large
and so you know what we have said i
believe on air and certainly certainly
we have said it to each other and and to
our children
and to others
uh is that in fact and and we are not
the only ones to say this uh that this
may in fact function
as the vaccine we all wanted
and that it may actually be you know
the thing that finally allows
the the
idiotic and presumably self-serving but
certainly not serving any of the rest of
us uh public health policies and public
health officials to stand down already
and
allow us back the things they took from
us that they never had any right to take
from us so in fact um it would make
sense it it is not my choice having
apparently contracted omicron uh to give
it to someone at the grocery store i'm
not allowed to make that choice um but
we certainly within our family ought
have the choice to say you know what um
we're not vaccinated
against covid with the existing vaccines
uh this variant flew in from we don't
know where it appears to be
easy to get and very easy to survive and
hey let's do that
so
we you know the the rules around
quarantining if you've been in contact
with someone who's positive makes some
sense because you're not allowed to make
that choice for other people but within
a family you can make that choice
so i want to go back and and just fine
tune a couple things here and i think
there's a i think in some sense the
value of this podcast is hearing you and
me talk about how we see these things
and and getting it uh precise is going
to help other people know how to think
about it
there is this question of whether or not
omicron i mean some people have raised
the possibility that some entity maybe a
state or who knows what entity could
have released omicron
uh as a white hat
uh
contagious vaccine
that would solve the problem by giving
people natural immunity
and uh basically
taking us out of the hands of our inept
at best public health authorities i want
to point out
whether or not anybody might have
intentionally done that i want to point
out the important distinction i think
this is something that we covered on our
last private q a but have not covered on
dark horse and i hope that if i if we
did cover it on the main dark horse
uh podcast that people will forgive me
for the repetition
but
many vaccines in fact many of our best
vaccines are what's called
attenuated virus vaccines attenuated
virus vaccine is a true virus a living
virus that is capable of infecting you
but does not cause serious disease now
these vaccines can be excellent in fact
they tend to be excellent because since
they do cause an actual infection they
play right into the immune system's
tendency to fight infection and to learn
the formula right they tend to be very
good at creating a robust immune
response a long-lasting one
so an attenuated virus vaccine knowing
nothing else is a good thing
there is a slight hazard to it the
slight hazard is that because you're
dealing with a live
creature
it can evolve and change and so although
the virus that is used for these
vaccines when they are manufactured is
not dangerous
one could conceivably evolve a trick
that its ancestor did not know and it
could do something new either through
recombination or mutation now that's not
very likely because those vaccines are
not contagious between people you have
to get injected with them
and then you get this minor infection it
causes immunity and you walk away with
the ability to spot that pathogen before
it makes you sick
so if this omicron is either somebody's
intentional project which to me seems
unlikely but definitely possible or an
accidental attenuated version of sars
cov2 that functions like a vaccine it
has one
crucial difference the crucial
difference
is that it is contagious in fact it's
highly contagious
so
that makes it even more frightening
because although omicron may be creating
less severe disease it could evolve into
something else and as people have begun
to learn the rules of thumb that we talk
about about
viruses evolving to become
less virulent don't they are rules of
thumb they are not absolute rules and
they are especially likely to be upended
by a virus that wasn't natural to begin
with as this one appears not to have
been
so
we have something that may well function
as an excellent very high quality
attenuated virus vaccine that gives
people permanent immunity and could
restore planet earth to its prior state
where we can go about doing our business
and not worrying about
covet 19.
we don't know what variant comes next
what that might descend from omicron it
does not appear that omicron descended
from delta which is one of the things
that raises the question of whether or
not it came from a lab it appears to
come from a much earlier ancestor that
apparently was off the map and then
returned suddenly with the subject here
that um what you just said may throw an
error for people because the standard
way of understanding evolution
is as if in a line that a begets b
begets c b it's b gets d even when
you're talking about not just
individuals but species and instead what
we have here and i don't have any
ability to share my screen with our
setup right now so i can't show you like
a phylogenetic tree um but you might
have a a precursor organism that beget a
and the beget um
delta
or you know from from a so you know the
original variant may have in fact
created delta but omegran may have come
from one of those ancestors rather than
and it seems really clear that it did
not
uh evolve straight up from from delta so
it's not it's not a linear
transformation it's a branching
formation and everyone is familiar with
those trees um but the implication of
the trees is often subtle
and in this case we have uh two things
one delta is not the
ancestor as far as anyone can tell
um
that is not hard to explain on the basis
that it could evolve from some other
strain circulating somewhere but it
appears to be from an early strain that
spent a lot of time not evolving and
then evolved very rapidly that's the
perplexing thing but anyway let's put
that mystery aside
um
we have a
highly transmissible
less virulent it's not a safe
variant but it seems to cause a lot less
death certainly than delta did that that
opens the possibility especially since
it is so contagious of it creating herd
immunity of it creating a population in
which most people have had it recovered
and aren't vulnerable and therefore
as we talked about early in the pandemic
if the r factor drops below one that is
to say that your average infected person
has a strain that has a uh
a better chance of not finding a next
victim than it has of finding a next
victim
right if we reach that state the thing
heads towards extinction
now that could result in another variant
popping up those dynamics are
interesting and and uh difficult to
fathom at one level but nonetheless this
could be the answer assuming it doesn't
evolve into something worse
for people like us
we have a question that unfortunately we
don't have enough information to answer
perfectly we have to take a guess and
the guess is
are we better off
contracting omicron and getting the
immunity that comes from it knowing that
that immunity probably will cover future
variants that there is probably a limit
to how long it can do that
but are we better off getting suffering
the disease
accepting whatever long-term
consequences of the disease there may be
including very few that's one
possibility a likely one
or are we better off trying to stave off
the disease
not getting the immunity and therefore
being vulnerable to the next set of
variants that comes along that's the
question people have to answer and so
what heather is saying here
is
you obviously don't have the right to
decide this for anybody else right you
don't have the right to decide this for
somebody at the grocery store but
shouldn't we inside of our family be
able to decide you know what omicron is
not um a perfect vaccine that is one
that is so subtle in its infection that
you can't even detect the symptoms but
it certainly does seem to be vastly
safer than the landscape we've just
emerged from
should we effectively accept that
infection
as a vaccine that is far safer
many of us would argue including heather
and me than the current set of vaccines
that we have should we accept that
immunity
and
move on and as a family it would seem
that we have the
moral right to do that and that
logically speaking there is a very
strong argument to be made
um
and i will i will point out we've got a
prior case of a different
virus in which we have a kind of
uh analog for this thinking which is
chickenpox
so when heather and i were children in
the 70s and 80s
when somebody in a community
came down with chickenpox there was very
often a decision
to have children who did not have
chickenpox
play in close proximity to the child who
was infected
in the hope that they would contract it
and the logic
was
that chickenpox became more dangerous
the later in life you got it and
therefore contracting it early would
provide natural immunity and prevent
infection now
i don't know whether our parents
generation was right to expose us to
chickenpox because
chickenpox actually remains in your
system for life
and it returns late in life as shingles
so i don't know if having gained those
chickenpox infections in an effort to
gain natural immunity
made any sense but i do know that people
have been through similar logic before
and their answer was not
resist the disease at all costs their
answer was the disease you
face as a child may be better than
facing it later in life a pattern that
is
also clearly true of
of sars kovi too
um and that we ought to be having that
conversation
given that it does not appear that
omicron is controllable in terms of its
spread across the population should we
not be considering embracing the natural
immunity and frankly using all of the
tools that we have discovered that work
to treat the disease in order to manage
it so that the moderate level of danger
it seems to pose is reduced to uh
one that exposes very few to anything
serious
yeah um
so you got
well i mean there's a lot more to say uh
you know we we are in the position uh in
our family of trying to live by
rules that we don't believe are rational
there's a question about um how
i guess i
i don't want to say that to our audience
because um
because i don't i don't think i don't
think we are i think you know we today
we discovered
that yes what i suspected
um we basically got a confirmation from
a doctor that we trust very much that
given the particular nature of my
symptoms which again i'm fine right um
he he said yeah you got omar kron you
just do
that means that we had to completely up
end plans um to give talks at a
conference we've been looking forward to
for a very long time next week we had to
cancel our travel we had to cancel the
plans we had to you know change a whole
lot else because getting on a plane
if you've recently had omicron which is
in the vast majority of people
less impressive as an illness than a
cold
is
frankly reason to have you strung up by
your heels in the court of public
opinion at the moment and we have
stopped talking about all of the other
insane things that people do all the
time that put people at risk and we have
stopped talking about the trade-offs in
general in society and how it is that we
have to make decisions knowing that
everything that we do comes with some
rest the idea that that
the idea that disappearing the risk on
this one thing to zero the decreasing it
to zero is the way to be a mature and
responsible adult no it is not it is the
way to be compliant and childish and to
basically assure the authorities that
next time they want to get you to do
something you're gonna do it
so you know we we did we did cancel our
plans to travel starting tomorrow um
because
because we are public enough about our
positions and who we are and
we cannot take the risk of actually
having possibly infected someone so we
will you know we are we are quarantining
this bit about i'm also isolating them
within the house
um so as to
to maybe not get you other you all sick
when
you know it's actually highly highly
transmissible and the idea we've got to
you know hvac we've got shared air flow
here
this this this feels this feels like
theater and it is theater and frankly
they've been putting us all through
theater for so long
uh and i'm i'm
pretty done well i hear ya i mean i
should point out to our audience
you have had two tests they have both
come back negative
we did not believe that negative result
and so we contacted a doctor to find out
whether in fact it was positive
right and here we are
an hour later
doing a podcast from two different rooms
because that's what the cdc says we
should do
we have
told you the audience as you know most
of what the cdc says we should do is
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's not going to
work in this house right but we have an
obligation to our children right we have
an obligation to our children to not
make them vectors of something even if
the thing that they would be vectoring
is arguably very strongly in the favor
of the people who might be infected in
fact both of their schools appear to
have
rampant omicron infections right at the
moment i guess i i wanted to say that i
don't actually know how the rest of the
country looks um in this regard and you
know i know that omicron is everywhere
but in portland the schools are insane
like two of the high schools shut down
and they're going to go back to remote
for six days
and one of the schools uh
the schools that one of our the school
that one of our children is at had what
did you say 19 teachers out yesterday
something like that did i make that
number up i think it was actually
somewhere in the 20s and 17 of them were
confirmed covet or something like that
yeah it's just i mean it's not it's it's
one of these big-ish schools but it's
not
that big that's an ins that's an
incredible amount of people out and at
our other sun school um there are
tremendous number of of student and
faculty out and another school that we
know of what did what was the number
zach if you can hear this what did what
did you say that the other school had
like sixty percent
say again
sixty percent six zero sixty percent of
was that everyone or just students
students
so so i couldn't hear him he said
students
okay sixty percent of students are out
of one school so we always heard behind
closed doors here it's insane um but you
know that's
that's probably for the best well and
these schools at
that's at two of those schools one of
the schools we have no way of knowing
but to the schools the vast majority of
these kids are vaccinated
which is
which is almost certainly not good for
them but omicron might be get it over
with get your infection
get your immunity and move on well wait
a second
i agree that given what we know that's
the obvious right answer
there is also that which we do not know
right so if somebody released omicron as
a white hat exercise in returning earth
to planet uh returning a planet earth to
normal yeah they took a massive gamble
on our behalf which probably they didn't
have a right to do yeah right because it
could evolve into something that is
outside of their understanding i don't
know maybe it has a kill switch in it or
more likely
it's a natural derivative of this
unnatural virus
and uh it had there's some weird
explanation for where its ancestor was
hanging out and not evolving for all of
that period of time but
nonetheless we've got a situation in
which
um
let's put it this way i mean again i
don't think incompetence could possibly
explain the horrifying nature of our
public health response to covid it's on
beyond what incompetence can account for
incompetence could get you arguably to a
random response it cannot get you to a
response that is the inverse of the
right response which is again and again
what we have so these people are
absolutely awful at their job is it
because of corruption is it because um
they have some kind of insanity that has
not been publicly disclosed i don't know
but the point is i actually and i and i
said this on my substance this last week
they are either awful at their jobs or
they are awful at the jobs that we have
been told they are trying to do right
that's right as you know as we have as
we have talked about several times it's
really a very different question we have
been told that they're trying to do a
job and if they are really truly trying
to do the job that we are told they are
trying to do they're doing it abysmally
abysmally but the idea that this many
people in this many positions of power
are doing this bad job
is rather
rather unlikely and does point to at
least an alternative hypothesis that
they are not doing the job they're not
even attempting to do the job that we
think they are attempting to do right
and actually nowhere are they doing it
worse than in the u.s right there are
some ways in which we are lagging behind
australia and canada in terms of some of
the truly draconian nonsense but in
terms of their actual effect at
controlling
kofit we have an appalling response and
the question is do you really want to
listen to these same people who have
failed who have actually
raised the bar of failure on kovid for
the world again and again do we really
want to listen to them as to what the
right response to this is
no there's no way that we do especially
when
i mean look the evidence is actually
mounting and i don't want to claim it's
conclusive but the evidence is mounting
that actually
vaccination with the current vaccines
makes you more likely to catch omicron
not less likely
so in light of that fact why is the
recommendation
why is there not even a pause right why
are they not gathered in a conference
room and saying look omicron is a
different beast right it has a different
it poses a different risk
it may be the opportunity that we wanted
we've got prototype vaccines that
frankly
um by any normal definition
are a cartoonish failure right
the feeble immunity that they create is
not
normal for vaccines and everybody knows
that what vaccine needs to be boosted
every six months
right and for this virus that we're
because we're running the risk we've got
an adverse event signal that's through
the roof the claim is oh that doesn't
mean anything because anybody can file
an adverse event okay but then that
means we have no information on how many
adverse events is it doesn't mean that
there are no adverse events we have a
massive signal we've got some people
telling us it doesn't mean anything
that's not the same as information that
says it's safe
what's more we've got obvious problems
with myocarditis and pericarditis and
these are not minor diseases the heart
is not an organ that repairs it scars
over so likely people who have these
things even when they get better are
being robbed of years of life so the
question is yeah i'm not at all
comfortable with the idea that getting
omicron is a safe thing to do the
question is is it safer than continuing
to expose yourself to the public health
authorities and their lousy advice on
how to manage your health and
i i don't think that argument can be
made so really that that's the question
for us citizens
right
are we again going to continue to take
advice from the same people who failed
all the way here
i i vote no
um i'd like to
read a poem
if i may sure
and this is um i i guess from your from
i mean i can't even stop you without
violating quarantine
you could break my isolation to come in
here um
so this is in the sun uh this magazine
which i which we subscribe to which i
like a lot um
from the october 2021 issue and um
i'll just read this without comment
first and then i'll comment afterwards
by a woman named alison luderman it's
called a few days after my first vaccine
walking by the end this is the october
2021 issue so we know what vaccine she's
referring to a few days after my first
vaccine
walking by the lake i lose an earring
and don't even notice it at first
overwhelmed as i am by the strangeness
of everything
blocks later my hand reaches up to feel
that slight absence in one ear
so then i have to retrace my steps as
they say to do
past the guy jogging with his mask
pulled down on the hijab wearing
stroller pushing young mother in stylish
jeans and the homeless man emerging from
his tent on the banks of our urban oasis
bearing a boombox on one shoulder
and that's where i spot it lying on the
sidewalk miraculously untrampled small
precious found thing a turquoise oval
encircled with rows of beads given to me
with love by someone i haven't hugged in
more than a year
tiny rescue from the sea of loss just as
we seem to have found a raft to grab
onto in the wake of a shipwreck so vast
we cannot yet imagine the end of it
i was struck by this poem
read it several times now
because i think it finally gave me some
insight that i've been looking for
into the mindset of the people who
really believed and many of whom still
believe
that
the vaccines are going to be our
salvation
this is this this tells us that the last
lines
about the earring but we know what she's
talking about tiny rescue from the sea
of lost just as we seem to have found a
raft to grab onto in the wake of a
shipwreck so vast we cannot yet imagine
the end of it
the vaccines are around the vaccines
have been promoted by these same health
officials who have had incoherent after
incoherent damaging after damaging
recommendation and
and uh and
mandate in many cases
that that come down on us with regard to
this thing and they are the ones who
successfully sold to many many people
the idea that there is one and only one
solution for you
it will be the vaccine that is the only
thing that will help you
these are the same people who will not
talk about repurposed drugs they will
not talk about vitamin d they will not
talk about the value and virtue and
wisdom and health of moving your body
and losing weight and eating real food
they will not talk about any of those
things the only thing they talk about is
the vaccine and so in a honestly pretty
hippy crunchy liberal dippy magazine
like the sun which i love
we have a poem that ends just as we seem
to have found a raft to grab onto
no these vaccines aren't that they're
not that and every passing week assures
us that that's not the case so
how do we
how do we talk to the people who still
think that they're the raft
and that those of us who didn't grab
onto the raft
are not actually sinking them
so
the
i'm struck frequently you know you
mentioned at the beginning of the
podcast that the first tripwire we hit
was the lab leak i don't actually feel
that it was a tripwire because
you know i think of them actually as
third rails
and that one
we touched it and
i think people were already clear enough
that something about the story of the
origin of this virus was uh
phony enough
that
um
we didn't suffer the same fate as
discussing early treatment
i think you're misremembering how hard
it was for the first year actually
um that maybe let's let's put it aside
though nonetheless being steeped in the
question of lab leak and then finding
ourselves with an appalling cartoonish
upside down public health response being
managed by
who
being managed by the dude who
circumvented the law
in order to make gain of function
research that he wanted done
moved to china
so that the congress's ability to
prevent gain of function research from
being done
explicitly because it could cause a very
serious pandemic
he wanted to override that so
once we are being fed
i mean if that was ineptitude fine but
the point is is that not sufficient
ineptitude that this person couldn't
possibly be put in charge of dealing
with the pandemic right and having
failed to deal with the pandemic
couldn't possibly be left in charge and
certainly that same person who overrode
the ban on gain of function research and
offshored it
to china that that guy couldn't possibly
be the one to decide whether we should
just double down on the same vaccines in
light of omicron or maybe switch gears
why is that same guy in charge of the
question right that should be on
everybody's mind this is a path charge
not just of the question with regard to
the vaccines but
the only two possible drugs that have
been considered which turn out to be
both ineffective and toxic
um are the ones that are produced by the
profit-making entities as well right and
i would just add to that list of
amazing anomalies you know how many
times were we shouted out about the
uh supposed failure of uh randomized
controlled trials uh as evidence for
drugs that uh in a clinical setting
clearly work but you know we have a
randomized controlled trial that that
says fluvoxamine works extremely well
and it's not like that has been rushed
to the forefront of the standard of care
so
we have a
an incoherence right we had to do
everything to rush these vaccines to
market in a single year and it is an
impressive feat to have done it
irrespective of whether or not the
vaccines
are something that should be
contemplated by
people but nonetheless we were in this
incredible rush to get a vaccine out the
door and now it's been a year and we're
suck we're stuck with the same
vaccine it hasn't even been updated with
respect to antigen right we were in such
a rush we're now rushing with the
malnupiravir right um but we have a drug
that has passed randomized controlled
trial appears to have a very good effect
and there doesn't seem to be any
movement on it at all what is this this
is all true but i think we're talking
across purposes and i think maybe you
and i are just in different places with
regard to what is
gripping us most at the moment about the
utter absurdity of the moment that we're
living in
and i for for months now really have
been trying to figure out what's in the
heads of the
of just the people
who are going along with this and
helping making helping make these
policies these insane policies stick and
persist
and this poem i feel like gave me some
insight and what i don't know is
you know how
how to reach
such people you know you and i have both
talked about
things that we do you know eavesdropping
when we're out not that that's gonna
happen for a few days here but um or you
know just
raising anything that sounds like
non-narrative non not on narrative
doubts
in casual interchanges and being not at
this point surprised by the vast
majority of people who immediately grasp
onto that and go like oh yes yes i don't
see it the way i'm being told i see it
right and i mean i had an interchange
this week with a woman
who i do know in passing um but who i
thought was totally on board who just
got boosted
uh recently and is done
she is
done
the side effects she's experiencing the
fear now of what she has done to herself
and the fights that she is having with
family and friends over her
refusal to engage in the cognitive
dissonance anymore
is extraordinary
this reflects what a lot of people are
going through but how
you know how
how to be open
and honest and honorable enough
to reach more to reach the people who
would write a poem
that seems so earnest
and has so misplaced its faith in that
raft the vaccine is these vaccines are
no right
well but i think in some sense it's the
same thing right
i'm frequently asked to isolate the
issues from each other all right let's
leave aside the issue of of repurposed
drugs let's talk about the vaccines and
the answer is you can't actually
separate those because the whole
argument in favor of taking a vaccine
this novel
and applying it so broadly is that we
didn't have a choice and to the extent
that we did have a choice and that
choice was driven off the map first in
order to make the argument that well
okay it's novel but we don't really have
a choice the point is those are two
sides of the same coin and so the sense
that the person who sees the vaccines as
the raft
is conveying is a sense that was
cultivated for them it's not a natural
conclusion
right we would be somewhere very
different if doctors had been allowed to
do their thing which some great doctors
did right
doctors are supposed to be scientists
when they have an emergent condition
they are supposed to say well here are
the symptoms and this is what i think it
implies about what's taking place inside
of this person and here are some
compounds that have this and that effect
and i'm going to try them
and they are supposed to learn and then
they are supposed to talk to each other
and that process is supposed to make
doctors better and better at treating
the disease and what we did instead was
we had some top-down bureaucratic thing
telling doctors what they were allowed
to think what they were allowed to try
what they were allowed to discuss it has
literally removed licenses it has fired
people who concluded things that were
contrary to the public health authority
and it has created
an environment in which basically you
have two choices you either embrace the
advice of a public health authority that
is clearly mad
or you're on your own and
neither of those are good choices
but it is time that we the public i mean
in some sense aren't we stuck
when you and i were kids
the idea of entheogens
right these were very controversial and
the idea that a person might actually
have the right to ingest a mushroom that
would alter the way they saw the world
that was not understood to be a right by
most people and some of us said well
what is the basis on which a government
tells you you can't alter your thinking
by eating a mushroom that does not
appear to be toxic right why does the
government get to do that and of course
you know in
2020 2021 2022 we're waking up to the
fact that maybe the government doesn't
have that right and in fact
there are therapeutic benefits to these
things but why is this situation any
different right you've got a variant out
there
it is not safe
but you are being offered other
alternatives that aren't safe you're
being offered vaccines that aren't safe
and you're being offered offered the
gamble that you will face future
variants that are even much less safe do
you not have a right to decide for
yourself that actually you know what
given everything i know about this
disease and given what i know about the
hazard of omicron that i'm better off
contracting it and if you're really in
good shape you can actually manage the
disease with many of the tools that the
renegade doctors have discovered works
right are you not entitled to do that in
consultation with your doctor and if not
why not
this isn't a perfect segue but i have
one paragraph
from nobel laureate carrie millis to
share so this is
this book which some of you will be
familiar with dancing naked in the mine
field
carrie mullis of course uh won the nobel
for uh
inventing pcr polymerase chain reaction
uh which is now being used um to for
some of the tests
for uh for kovid and he famously before
he died in 2019
he wasn't that old
he died younger than he ought to have
um
he famously said there's no way pcr
should be used
to diagnose
a pathogen in a body it's just it's too
strong it's too powerful to process
um would you say that's an accurate
description of that yeah let me let me
fill it in one step further the idea is
polymerase chain reaction because it is
an exponent it is inherently exponential
can amplify the tiniest signal and turn
it into a readable uh piece of data and
so the point is
let's say that you have a pcr machine
and it's on a coveted ward and you turn
the cycle thresholds way up right what
you do is you end up amplifying
contamination so that many tests come
back positive when in fact they
shouldn't and so his point was you can't
use it
right there's virus everywhere right
this is one of the things you learn you
know in a laboratory settings it's very
hard to control this stuff and so if you
have an amplifier and basically the
point is it can amplify any level any
low level of signal into one that is
then going to trigger your test it's not
an appropriate diagnostic at the very
least you would have to figure out how
to calibrate it and you would have to
hold the cycle thresholds perfectly
still so that you can see over time what
was changing right you have to have a
definition for what it is to be
positive with covid
rather than a floating definition that
allows you to effectively shunt people
into that category by amplifying
contamination
yeah uh so there's a ton in this book
that is extraordinary um
and i haven't read all of it but and
this
this could have been said by a lot of
scientists but it's amazing
how many scientists are not saying this
now the scientists who would tell you to
follow the science are mostly not saying
this right now again kerry mullis
claims made by scientists in contrast to
claims made by movie critics or
theologians can be separated from the
scientists who make them it isn't
important to know who isaac newton was
he discovered that force is equal to
mass times acceleration
he was an antisocial crazy bastard who
wanted to burn down his parents house
but force is still equal to mass times
acceleration it can be demonstrated by
anybody with a pool table and familiar
with newton's concepts
this is just a perfect summary of the
point that you know again one that we've
been making over and over and over again
but you know the claims made by people
in white coats
with no reference to the actual data and
no ability for those of us who could
potentially understand it to see that
data amount only to their opinions that
it's not science speaking that is
someone who may or may not have an
appropriate credential making it making
opining
that is them opining that is not them
sharing a scientific conclusion it
sounds like it is and they want us to
believe it is but we can see from you
know the rapidity with which for
instance the cdc is changing their minds
about stuff and the fact that what you
know i
don't remember where it is
but apparently the newest thing is uh
you know what is wallensky and the rest
of her team
focusing on they just hired a pr firm
now at one level
okay they got a pr disaster on their
hands for sure
but they have a pr disaster on their
hands in part because they have an
actual scientific disaster in their
hands and when i read that they had
hired a pr format this is one of the
main approaches that they were taking to
try to fix the messaging problem i was
reminded of and you know exactly where
this is going brett but this was the
move at evergreen about two weeks into
the mess there instead of fixing it and
turning it around and being reasonable
and seeing logic and having compassion
for people with real complaints
in that case or
recognizing
what the data are actually saying and
not calling people crazy and then having
things that were called conspiracy
theories six months ago now accepted
quietly without anyone ever saying
anything instead of actually fixing the
problems at the agency they're gonna
hire a pr firm to figure out how to how
to cozy it up and make it look good
this is not what a
science agency in the united states in
2022 should be doing obviously this is
not where their priorities should be
um i'm this is i'm dragging this way out
of the archive here but there was a
moment there was a guy
uh in the
george w bush administration i think he
was a democrat named delelo he was like
the token democrat the george w bush
administration
brought in
and so he was in the white house and he
reported
that he was horrified to discover
that there was
no policy wing to the administration
his point was the policy was coming from
somewhere it was being fed in and the
entire thing was about presentation
right that something was authoring the
plan and it had nothing to do with the
people in the white house the people in
the white house were a figurehead right
and
of course the world came crashing down
on him and he was you know
exiled and all of the terrible things
happened that you would expect but the
point was it was one of those brief
peaks behind the curtain oh
you just discovered that your government
is being inhabited by something that
hasn't even thought about the
implications of policy because that's
not the point which goes back to your
point at the beginning of the podcast
where you were uh saying that um
they may not be so terrible at their
jobs we just may not know what their
jobs are
and you know i agree in fact i think
somewhere months ago i said i thought i
was betting that fauci is actually
excellent at his job um it just isn't
well he's been at something um
but you know we
well let's put it this way there's an
interesting discussion beginning to
bubble up behind the scenes and a lot of
these interesting discussions happen
amongst people who have crossed the
rubicon and uh are in the hinterlands
um months before they show up in public
so you know mass formation showed up in
the malone podcast on joe rogan but we
had been talking about mass formation
for quite some time uh the matthias
desmond model and you and i had been
talking about the
impression that we had that there was
clearly some kind of emergent psychosis
overtaking the world right we saw it and
we named it that before we knew what
mass formation psychosis even was so i
like desmond's formulation but
nonetheless the point is there's a long
discussion of what really matters that
shows up before the public suddenly
becomes aware that there's a discussion
at all and so the discussion i want to
reference now there's a discussion
beginning to happen
about
whether
[Music]
bodily autonomy is really even the point
right some of us i've been very careful
not to invoke bodily autonomy because as
i frequently say there are scenarios in
which you can imagine that mandates
would be justified and i don't want to
say anything that suggests that the very
fact of mandates are invalid however
the question you know so people will
maybe have seen me say or tweet
not these vaccines
not these public health authorities not
this pathogen right mandates fails on
three separate grounds here these
vaccines aren't effective enough or safe
enough the pathogen isn't dangerous
enough universally enough
um and the public health authorities are
not free of corruption enough that we
could justify mandates but not even
right not even close here's where i
think this is headed though
i believe it is conceivable
that you could have
a governmental structure good enough to
be entrusted with the question of
mandates in a sufficiently serious
situation
i don't believe that government has ever
existed i believe we have to leave it
open as a theoretical possibility that
it is not a fact of history that we've
had such governments and that we do or
don't have one now we have a terrible
instantiation but none of the
governments none of the human
architected governmental structures has
been up to that challenge which means
that at least we need we need a new
structure then because the existing
structures can't bring the best of
humanity out of us and give us the
government that maybe we deserve but
certainly we want right and i completely
agree we need to figure out what that
structure is as you and i argue in our
book it's not a structure that we can
blueprint nobody on earth knows how to
blueprint it but we could navigate to it
we could prototype our way to it we
could evolve our way to it but in the
present stuck with the governmental
structures that we have the argument
would be
these governmental structures are not up
to the challenge of mandating and
overriding bodily autonomy they are not
up to that challenge and in light of the
fact that they are not up to that
challenge and nothing could be done to
them that would make them up to that
challenge they are allowed one tool and
one tool only and that tool is
persuasion
right if they want us to take their
remedy because it is the right remedy
and because it is better than the others
and because that's how we will protect
each other their one tool
is to convince us
and they have completely failed to
convince us why
because the tools they have presented us
are completely crappy
because their corruption is so obvious
and because we can detect that what they
are doing is taking any counter-argument
and doing their best to silence it to
stigmatize it to shunt it off the side
of the map right so we know we're not
having a fair conversation about what
the best path forward is we can all see
that right that's why people are being
thrown off twitter and youtube
right that's what this is about it is
about creating the false impression that
their argument is actually robust when
it could not possibly be more feeble and
i don't know i'm sick of it and we are
now faced with omicron and we are
really left with the question of whether
or not the test did they pass the test
so well with respect to previous
variants that we are still listening to
their advice with respect to this one
even though this one is so different and
their advice hasn't changed doesn't that
tell you this isn't about us
this is about
their
i don't know i guess business interests
or whatever it is but it's certainly not
about us because the fact is the the
disease is so different the advice would
certainly have changed if this was any
sort of rational process and yet it
doesn't in fact what they do is they
pretend they they uh what's the
retcon they retcon things retcon
retroactive continuity where they tell
us oh
it was always the case that the vaccines
were designed to prevent serious disease
they were never designed to prevent
transmission of the disease so the fact
that they don't prevent you from
contracting or transmitting the disease
and they don't reduce viral loads oh
that was all expected it's all part of
the design well [ __ ]
right we all heard them tell us that it
was about control
i'm reminded as you talk
um you know just as maybe there are
maybe many of them are actually doing
their jobs very very well and we just
don't know what their jobs are
um
maybe the public health policy is very
much doing what it's supposed to do and
we have just been misled by its
packaging
a point you have made in different forms
in in many ways that because it has the
words public health in it we assume that
it's about public health but that's our
bad for being so gullible
and i'm reminded of the thinking of the
great john taylor gatto recently
deceased
who was an extraordinary educator and
who wrote among other things uh weapons
of mass instruction
and dumbing us down
and i've talked about his work um before
on this podcast but uh in one of his
books he goes through a history of
compulsory schooling which if memory
serves sort of emerges from
german german model in the late 19th
century which the americans um
import and it's it's basically like the
robber barons
the you know the the the rich tycoons of
the turn of the 19th and 20th century
who need
mindless workers
to do the work of the new industrialized
world post-industrial revolution that
explains the format of schools
that schooling is not about creating
well-informed citizens who can make
decisions for themselves it is precisely
about creating cogs that is in fact the
point
and this this feels a bit like that you
say school you say education you imagine
sweet children bursting out of a
classroom into recess and then going
back into
into the classroom to learn the good
things that they need to learn and maybe
that was never the point at all
and maybe the point of public health
policy has not been at least for this
for this little pandemic of ours the
entire world has been dragged through
for almost two years now has never the
public health response has never been
about public health but about but about
compliance but about seeing how far you
can push a population
and
maybe as a practice run i don't know but
they do know a whole lot about how all
of us will behave now they know who will
tend to be compliant they know who will
carry water for them
they know who will ramp up their fears
because it feels good because they can
get other people to do things based on
their fears
there's a whole lot of knowledge now
about what different quadrants of
society and what different individuals
will do and will not do
and
that is
dangerous you know we have been
experiencing the death of privacy in
many forms by a thousand cuts for
decades now but this feels like
you know maybe the final blow
but
i don't even i don't know how to phrase
this so that it will
be hearable
we
i know that natural rights is a fraught
concept but the thing is
we are human beings
we get one life
in this life
halfway through for us or more
suddenly a virus that appears to be the
product of really bad decision making
emerges out of a lab in china
that really bad decision making
had
anthony fauci as a prominent
he was
at least an architect of the offshoring
of the work that seems to have caused
this pandemic
and yet he is also
somehow in a prominent position where he
gets to tell you and me you having
apparently contracted a descendant of
the virus that he stupidly had
engineered
somehow he gets to tell you and me how
we are to manage the consequences of
this you and i are phds in evolutionary
biology
we are capable of looking at this and
saying i don't think that solution
you've handed me is any good at all and
here's why
i am also capable as you are capable of
saying you know what
i've talked to dr corey
i've heard what he has to say i've heard
him revise his understanding of things
in light of new evidence we've talked to
dr mccullough
france
and light of what and in light of new
variants
right the people who are thinking on
their feet are also recognizing that no
matter how much information they had
last month what is happening now may be
different because the informa it's not
just that the information is new to them
but what is true is actually changing
this is also true right and you know
we've heard from dr malone himself
vaccinated right
the inventor of the technology that
underlies these vaccines we've heard him
talk about the hazard of of these things
to us how is it that we attempting to
act responsibly and in the interests of
ourselves and of our family are not
entitled to make those calls
how can it be it just seems to me
so
such an inversion of decency that
anthony fauci has more say over what we
are allowed to think and not think do
and not do than we do when anthony fauci
has demonstrated at best incompetence he
is a key player in the escape of this
virus into the world the creation of it
and the escape and all of that ought to
have him absolutely silenced in this
conversation responsible people who have
proven that they can handle the
complexities ought to be in a position
of responsibility it's some kind of
kafka s nightmare where anthony fauci
has all of the say over what we get to
do
i mean look
somehow it would appear that you
actually have contracted a virus that
seems to have been engineered downstream
of a fouchy offshoring grant through
through
eco health alliance right that's an
amazing fact
right that error in judgment has reached
out and touched you at the cellular
level
frankly
as we have talked about
i
i will be glad to have had it and in
fact it's been so
trivial by and large that it was never
really that much of a big deal
i am angry at the timing in part because
this place that we were going to be
going was florida which we've spent
almost no time at all
um but by all accounts uh
one of our son's friends spent the
winter break in florida and came back
saying came back to portland oregon
saying it feels so normal there
it feels so
normal
and uh we've been in texas recently
enough to say that that's largely the
case there too we're just in austin but
um
you know a lot of the country doesn't
feel quite so crazy so somehow
some some number of
other political authorities not public
health authorities perhaps are saying uh
to the talking head
uh that fills the screens if you turn it
on uh no actually
not not your choice
and um you know this
we have been hearing too uh from many
conservatives in the last few months
saying this is our objection
to uh liberal forms of government
because no government
will be good enough like this this is in
fact uh the the response that that we're
getting from
from
honest wonderful conservatives who say
no now you see nice well and you know i
to the extent that that is their point
it is absolutely right and i would just
add it's not like
governments don't have the right to make
policy but the point is the tool by
which they should get there
is persuasion they have to persuade us
that this is actually the right path and
they mandating it is obscene in light of
where this virus came from and in light
of what they've done to both the
discussion and to the tools available to
you and your doctor in order to deal
with the condition
and our point would be
you know to your point earlier they need
we need to invent something by which the
structures are in place to allow people
to be their best self so that we can
have a governance structure that is
effective because
we need
we need some we need global governance
of some things because we have global
systems
so the fact that we haven't yet figured
out a way to not have it be corruptable
does not mean that the answer should be
or can be therefore we can have no
system the the systems which need
governing exist therefore they need
governing
well and in fact
that didn't quite work but there are
systems that need governing that are
global
and those systems aren't going anywhere
therefore we need to figure out a way to
govern them yeah we have to we have all
of the processes that need governing
have to be governed at a level that is
capable of managing them you know there
are some global processes i don't think
most of us who have seen the appalling
failure of government want to see
everything or even anything managed at
that level that doesn't have to be but
um but nonetheless we you know
we are stuck on a very tiny rock and
there are global processes and
externalities and they have to be
addressed uh you know in some sort of
adult form which is not taking place
but
at the moment we are
uh
we are in the most
bizarre upside down world conceivable
and you know i'm even thinking as we're
talking here right i think the
conversation that you and i are now
having oddly a couple of rooms apart
um
is
what a normal conversation between
evolutionary biologists who are
uh long and i think happily
married
would have about their family's
well-being we know from what people say
to us that hearing our conversations is
keeping them sane and at the same moment
i think this very conversation where i
think frankly both you and i are um
at the end of our patience
with this insane
nonsense this conversation as healthy
and reasonable as it is as careful as it
is
is actually probably a danger to our
channel
right that in fact the very just as our
public health response is upside down it
is the very conversations you most need
to hear that are most likely to be uh
mislabeled as disinformation and uh
thrown off of these platforms and i
don't know i i hope i hope people uh
will will
keep track of that hazard and i hope
people will also keep track of the fact
that we are
being very careful to point out it's not
like we're saying hey omicron is a uh a
an attenuated virus vaccine that just so
happens to be the kind you don't have to
drive anywhere to get because it'll come
find you right that's not what we're
saying and in fact there's there's a
there's a danger here that i can't
i can't rule out right just as
chickenpox comes back as shingles we
don't know what sarsko v2 does decades
later to people who've had it i'm not
eager to have had it but as between the
choice of facing the risk that omicron
might do something that we don't know
decades after one has had it and the
risk that these vaccines are going to do
something of that nature i actually
think you've got a better shot with the
with the virus and who the hell are
these
out of control
public health officials to tell me
otherwise they have not demonstrated
that they have deep knowledge of this in
fact they've demonstrated the opposite
there's three things three more things
that i want to touch on before we
shut down the hour or however long we've
been going for
one of which is something you alluded to
just now
uh we met
uh
a number of
wonderful people fans of the podcast uh
in the in the three weeks since we've
been here
and you know we do at this point i don't
know
one time in three one time in four uh
that we go out
and
meet someone who is familiar with
recognizes us
uh and the conversations
to date have always just been
so
wonderful the um
the ways that people are taking solace
and
consolation and also knowledge from uh
from what we are sharing is
extraordinarily gratifying and we
appreciate it and
um furthermore it being since since we
last saw you it was before christmas
uh some number of people found the uh
the p.o box that we have listed or
in our darkhorse moderator uh where to
get it and send us gifts and we are the
recipients now of
a tremendous number of just wonderful
wonderful handmade like
you know beef tallow sabs and and
chocolates
and
uh and and wine and
and weavings and books
and really remarkable things that often
come with letters and often letters come
um you know without other things and
these letters too are amazing often
written in longhand sometimes typed um
also of course over email we get those
things but um
it really does
help us realize that we are not just
shouting into an abyss
but it makes me realize too how how much
harder it would be
not to be getting that reification and
so we you know we we know um
we know that for some people us not
being here for the last few weeks was
was hard and so here we are back a
couple rooms apart from one another but
back
um
one of the other things i wanted to
touch on before we go is before we move
into our q a is i want to talk about
brisket can we talk about brisket a
little bit oh hell yeah yeah
so um
one of the
the things that we have all been taking
in our family uh up until
uh i got i got the quran here um was we
were taking we were supplementing with d
and c and magnesium and zinc and
quercetin but we had run out of
quercetin a while back and i'd ordered
some and it never came uh so quercetin
is something that no one i know had
heard of before all of this but it's a
it's a zinc ionophore and so it's it's
found in in various plants uh it's a
zinc ionophore which means that it uh
facilitates the entry of zinc into cells
so if you take it with zinc you're more
likely to have the zinc actually do what
it needs to do but it also apparently
has a lot of uh antiviral and
anti-inflammatory effects on its own so
it's really it's it's it's quite a
valuable a tool in the arsenal on its
own
so finding myself unable to come up with
any any new pill form of corset 10 i did
what i should have done a long time
before and looked into it and found well
actually in supplement form as is the
case with many of these things it's not
that um
it it
most of it just goes right through you
you don't you don't take much of a dent
and you can increase the amount that
you'll take in if you eat it with a
fatty meal
but um still you're not getting that
much and really this is one of those
things that you're much better off
getting with your food and of course
that's true for almost everything
but the three primary food sources of
quercetin
are capers
okay
kale
and onions
and we actually do eat kale we ate kale
even before it went to that crazy
fashionable phase a while back at which
point i stopped eating kale because i
don't like to eat the fashionable things
at the moment but um i started replacing
it with collards and chard and such but
kale apparently is a good source of
quercetin so if you like it cool
continue eating that but also onions and
i think most americans actually have
enough of a taste for onions such that
if you cook at all
um upping your intake of onions in your
food at the moment is probably just a
good healthy thing to do so i decided to
i'd already actually by chance ordered a
brisket these
six six pound six or seven pound
grass-fed brisket uh and the recipe that
both you know brett you in the past and
i now am
using
um has you
thickly slicing eight onions
eight onions that then get cooked down
you know and we've got this giant
coconut this giant like crescent cocoa
that when i just poured the onions in um
it basically filled it to the rim and of
course it cooks down to not almost
nothing with that number of onions these
are big onions too
um
but
the house smells amazing
and the brisket is fabulous and it's got
a few other things in it too but not
that much you know it's got it's got a
little bit of fat to brown the brisket
and a little bit of in this case
gluten-free flour and some garlic and
carrots and such but mostly it's that
meat
um that you slow cook for hours to break
down all the connective tissues and just
make it melt in your mouth soft and
delicious and these onions that you have
prompted them a large reaction in and
gotten them to brown and then you just
slow cook it with the meat
forever and it's extraordinary and it's
an excellent source of quercetin which
is actually a terrific tool in your
arsenal right now in the for those of
you in the northern hemisphere even even
damn [ __ ] kophen but you know even
absent this particular virus like this
is this is this is flu season
not that anyone's heard of flu anymore
and who knows where all those diagnoses
are going but um this is the season when
you want the most um antiviral and
anti-inflammatory stuff on board so i
recommend quercetin in the form of
onions
that's point two you wanna you wanna say
something about yeah i do i i must i
have a uh a lifelong fondness of brisket
the recipe in question is one that my
grandmother used to make and it it's so
it's a family favorite and i'm also i
i think it is important to pass on the
important insight into what brisket
is um which has largely been lost but
the idea is brisket is a cut of beef
that is
an absolute delicacy it is top flight
stuff but only if you have an ungodly
number of hours to cook the stuff and so
the point is it was immigrant food
because the collagen in the brisket the
brisket is basically uh is it the
trapezius
on the shoulder blade uh muscle of the
cow
this beef is so tough right when if you
just cooked it quickly that it's almost
inedible
but if you can cook it for hours and
hours across the day then you break down
that collagen and it turns just so
incredibly tender and so the thing is
immigrants often had more time than
money and so you they could afford to
buy a cut of meat that wasn't good if
you cooked it quickly they could invest
the time cooking it all day
and it's just so delightful when you do
um all right i don't know if i
interrupted your your train of thought
no no absolutely not i have one one
third thing to touch on which has
nothing to do with anything else we've
talked about so if anything anything
more to say about brisket or covert or
anything go for it
um wrap up with kobe and i can say my
thing first
yeah i i don't have i think i think
we've pretty much said it all right so
um today would have been david bowie's
75th birthday
uh and i think i asked zach to queue up
uh a photograph i have no idea what
photograph of bowie he found because i i
only have the ability to text him so
zach can consequent hear that i am
asking for the bowie picture to show oh
i can't are we seeing a bowie picture
yes we are
so i can't even see what it is
can you hallucinate it
what era is it from like which oh it's
personal it's pretty it's pretty
wow i'm gonna get this way off but i
would say it might be 80s bowie
okay well so i don't oh this is terrible
i can't i can't see the picture that
he's shown um i don't i i i just right
before we came on i realized it was
bowie's it would have been bowie's 75th
birthday had he not died
um in like
2016 i think i remember like we were we
were right before we were gonna go to
ecuador with our class
and most of our students were young
enough that he hadn't really been that
important to them
um
but he was one of the very few and you
know he was
he was still obviously active at the
point that we were
uh we were of age listening to music but
he was also you know of an era that was
well before our time
and
he was one of the artists of the
musicians that really
when he died i felt like a light had
gone out in a way that
would never would never come back he was
just such a one-off brilliant
brilliant innovator across
so many domains and you know frankly one
of them
was of course the the gender bending
stuff
the um
you know the cross-dressing and
we could use his wisdom around that
because i'm sure that he was not
pleasing to those who have a very
traditional view of what gender is and
should be and where women should be and
where men should be
and uh to those people i would say you
need to look forward and stop looking to
the past for your
for your inspiration because
um because it's not the way things are
gonna
work and it's
it's not good for the vast majority of
us to be restricted to traditional
gender roles for instance
but bowie never thought he was a woman
right bowie never confused his um
his really all over the place sexuality
his sexual orientation his interest in
people of both sexes at a sexual level
or his interest in
uh female typical fashion and in
dressing up so that and in dressing up
with lots of makeup very fabulous very
fabulous
um as confusion about the underlying
reality
and that i you know i certainly wasn't
conscious of of that of my appreciation
of that when i was a huge fan an avid
fan of bowie in you know in the 80s when
i was a teenager um but i'm certain that
it that it affected my understanding of
what was possible and also
what you didn't need to do right like he
never needed to pretend to actually be a
woman to adopt a whole bunch of sort of
stereotypical affectations of of women
and some in some of his cosplay and then
to
to take that off and try another hat so
um i you know bowie
r.i.p you know he this was what now six
years ago um but i but i still i still
miss him in a way that
we don't usually miss the people we
never knew
yeah in some sense you know there's this
claim about uh you know
well the
you know the binary is just it's too
limiting you're born into a sex and then
that just tells you you know what the
limits of what you can do are and
bowie's point was like oh really what
limits are those you know that's right
that's right and this you know so the
talk that i was supposed to be giving in
in miami this week was exactly on sex
differences and gender differences and
what the difference is between sex and
gender and you know why sex is binary
and gender isn't but it's strongly
bimodal but you can move around on the
on the gender norms and boy bowie just
just exemplified this and he did so with
class
and he also we wouldn't know any of that
had he also not been a supremely
talented musician
and uh and songwriter as well
so i just wanted to to say something
about bowie since it is an anniversary
of
of his birth today yeah i i agree i i
also miss him he's one of those artists
that
reached out of their genre if they even
really had a genre and meant something
to a lot of us who would not ordinarily
you know i wasn't a big fan of glam rock
but david bowie was you know worth
crossing that boundary for
that's right
yeah
yeah
so
did you want to finish off with anything
i mean we got tons more here but this is
such a weird weird setting that uh it
will maybe we'll save most of the rest
of it huh yep
all right
um
so we'll be taking a break while we get
the q a ready for
you can ask questions at
www.darkhorseadmissions.com
any logistical questions you have
not questions for us for the q a but
logistical questions can go to
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
again consider joining our patreons uh
my sub stack is
naturalselections.substance.com is
almost all of the content is free i do
audio reads of most of the things
for the paying subscribers but almost
all of the articles are free so the ones
that i've referred to this hour you can
find without having to pay anything
um
yeah
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside and i will
add it is time for americans to join the
global fight against the mandates
consider joining us in washington d.c on
january 23rd or if you can't come to
washington wherever you may be we have
to rise up these mandates don't make
sense they are not responsive to the
change in this pandemic and that tells
you that they aren't about us in the
first place so please it is time
stand up
all right everyone thanks for joining us
and we will see you for q a in hopefully
about 15 minutes
be well everyone
[Music]
you